they are the faces of those feared lost
in the tragedy that has rocked this
island Community Police releasing photos
of seven of those feared dead following
Saturday's explosion in Saint Helia but
there may be more to come
among them 71 year old Raymond Brown
friend Terry Laman had known him for 40
years Rey was amongst a group of
Scottish leaders who came to Jersey in
the 60s and the 70s I've known Ray for
many many years as a quiet unassuming
lovely man
earlier today the chief minister of
Jersey joined more than a hundred other
government workers in leading a minute
silence
well everybody has really come together
um and and put the families of those who
are affected first and foremost in their
thoughts but also they have a great
sense of practicality and they all want
to help and support everybody that they
can
just what caused this huge explosion in
the early hours of Saturday is still
under investigation a key focus is the
fact that firefighters and the islands
utility company attended just hours
earlier to reports of the smell of gas
the company Island's energy says the
block of flats in question was not
connected to gas but that a Mains pipe
did run nearby it is now carrying out an
inspection of the whole of Jersey's gas
network but says that no problems have
been identified so far
the full picture of how and why this
happened won't be known for some weeks
down Whitehead Sky News in Jersey